les risques du nucléaire suite cinq ans
après la catastrophe de tchernobyl
un colloque franco soviétique vient de
se tenir à paris sur les conséquences de
ce drame
même si les soviétiques ont livré toutes
les informations utiles
certaines zones d'ombré subsistent en
particulier sur le renforcement des
sécurités à apporter aux centrales
nucléaires du même type
autrement dit des dizaines de tchernobyl
sont encore possibles comme va nous
expliquer cette enquête deux filles
dumez et claude sicard cette jeune fille
redoutent de ne jamais pouvoir avoir
d'enfant cinq ans après la catastrophe
de tchernobyl
si les techniciens sapta c'est bien ce
qui s'est passé les conséquences à long
terme en particulier médicales sont
beaucoup plus incertaine dans son
sarcophage de béton plein de trous le
réacteur numéro 4 de la centrale
soviétique ne finit pas de provoquer un
traumatisme social dans les populations
d'ukraine et de biélorussie sept
derniers république a d'ailleurs
récemment annoncé son refus total de
toute installation de centrales
nucléaires sur son territoire
il faudra longtemps pour rétablir là bas
la confiance des populations envers le
nucléaire mais le problème est qu'il
faudra d'abord renforcer la sécurité
dans toutes les centrales nucléaires
soviétiques actuelle et ce ne sera pas
simple ils ont besoin d'électricité
puisque déjà leur cycle sur économique
est très difficile et clichy sont privés
de cette électricité
ça va être encore plus catastrophique
avec l'accroissement du chômage etc
mais en même temps pour continuer à
produire cette électricité il faut
qu'ils améliorent la sûreté et ça ça
coûte quelque chose alors ils nous l'ont
dit carrément un sens sans complexe ils
attendent de la communauté européenne
qui a un programme principe à cette fin
une assistance non seulement technique
mais aussi économiques
les centrales soviétiques sont donc
peut-être notre épée de damoclès
actuelle mais comme l'a rappelé un
expert soviétique en citant dostoïevski
nous ne voulons pas d'un avenir radieux
si cela doit se faire avec les larmes
d'un enfant il faudra pourtant trouver
une solution sous peine de voir l'urss
sombrer dans des problèmes économiques
absolue
à